well a gallon bet my dinner power I've
got mine and I wrote it down enjoy the
video
I was Vince it was crying today I
remarked I was being really sneaky
though like you were being really was
yeah hey guys you're always no one can
possibly a train of its silly hey let me
just look at you and pull out my shotgun
oh hey hey hey
here I have another one I'm gonna shoot
you one time cry but I wanted to test
our faith you still deny tried doesn't
do any damage in the discombobulated er
it what the [ __ ] does that word mean I
don't got a little bit discombobulated
is all
keep your distance sorry someone's
actually set off like an incendiary
grenade in the market by the way but
makes that it wasn't hurt it's gonna be
yeah it's bangs as you can mix him
forever swear on your life hey what are
you doing with oranges don't you cry
don't you [ __ ] die statement I will I
would have stopped back by now I fight
with the trader oh yeah yeah all right
okay I'm gonna give you a test
[ __ ] in America yes or no yeah
well terrorism Pete what she said no
what I said yes if I'm innocent
she said no sorry max gotta happen
it's okay in the box that's why I
thought it was you they Skype you know
half the stuff like breaks up and
everyone's talking anyway uh yeah I
don't get back is I'm the hose I think
you're so cool
no I don't think no no no no I don't
think I'm cool huh no yeah I know yeah I
know I'm you born cool you are cool I'm
cool everyone this sucks
I think about it everyone form it in
their mouth go and do the box see ken
got it can't fake that bunny came to
[ __ ] my beautiful handsome main aim
definitely terrorism activity a box you
way are we playing prop hunt yeah we're
we're prop terrorism mmm in a box no I
see how it he it's chilled in the box
yeah I don't like feeling you guys you
guys like some chilling I didn't hear
the gunfire there's a dead body right at
the box which box are we talking to mind
how do you do hey hey makes it chilly
man makes it shoot at me stop it right
now set I stop if you stop I stop a visa
you shoot him it must be crying must be
great are you sure you
I'm big I must be crying
it must be tried yeah yeah lil I really
hope you guys are hurry up and get to
the box so you can investigate my body
but we [ __ ] bye
what do you mean oh dude does that's
been a while let's sue Jesus he plays he
plays game really well to you yeah but
he's sneaky he's too sneaky it makes me
uncomfortable I don't know who I can
trust
yeah exactly same would minx minx it's
like way too sneaky for your own good
it makes him the same way every time so
you can never tell exactly and it was a
zombie apocalypse I'd be like minx
there's the door it's like I couldn't
trust you in trouble entire sound I sure
as hell ain't trusting you now we see
how that way
okay can I trust okay cry let's trust
each other
I'm reducing each other in the preparing
phase yeah but we're building a trust
before that so you know what the [ __ ]
are you pointing at I don't know hey
that's that's part of the trust test how
are you shooting me without a gun I
can't see beyond this look like you're
trying to finger me finger McBrine
finger bang
I was fingering you it sounds like a
pretty good finger bang I know I came in
two seconds
ah you [ __ ] [ __ ] hey you guys are
close keep going keep going in there
keep going keep going keep going keep
going
not that crying other way no don't go
away from in yes just prolong the
inevitable can you're way off you're way
off you got to go more into Center Oh
Felix Lucy fans buddy wait no wait never
seen this map what's wrong with you
[ __ ] what you never what go make me
proud again
yeah yeah there you go dun dun okay
listen to the Starwood Sun check in the
background listen wrong barn episode 1
oh my gosh like white [ __ ] well this
sound is pretty epic hey you really
oughtta cry was Terris final oh I'm so
surprised
yep a finger mean so I at least got
something out of it go to jail exactly
hi Charlie goes for you gentlemen thanks
man you've done the whole shebang
produced it was yeah you're stupid you
go in you're terrible your ghosting was
abusive sir wrong turns and it's
frustrating okay so you just go out you
should be like go left okay
only terrorists don't have working I
shot someone that's how I shoot people
okay hey guys what I don't like in real
life
hey why did you shoot me when Ken was
behind me huh you trying to be sneaky
I'll find it Oh Gandalf pinkston's Fultz
Gandalf you can trust you know like you
know that's that PD player on YouTube
[ __ ] that guy [ __ ] [ __ ] how'd you
know it was my birthday
why'd you give me a shout-out buddy
well well I don't know I don't know
anything about that [ __ ] Channel I
just heard a [ __ ] screams all the
time and you think Lisa [ __ ] funny
but it's not funny okay okay can you get
into like my videos they I thought your
friends cutie pie can you put me in your
sub box well I take $12 charge for each
sub box I don't [ __ ] think I'm known
is that per month money people are gonna
take that seriously now
don't realize that there are channels
who actually do that [ __ ] they like
there are a lot that's really dumb what
why the hell are you following me
cuz I want to stay in there somebody
who's in it bingo that's me
that's a big spider is a boy I know how
trainers always by now it is hey we all
serve together we referenced and
everyone does it try to hold the barrel
oh wait I mean everyone is knotted who
smoked us who smoked us whether you Ken
was it you smoked with us
everyone is one others everyone is a
traitor hold the Box head the car the
mail car trinkets like okay Sophie who
shot who shot shoe shop I was your must
say the smoke shooting me right now
great flag cry great fun here maybe next
time we will actually work right well
now that it failed it will work next
time that's a great this basically speed
you have to fail to work I'm sorry have
you guys seen that twerking video on
YouTube oh my god oh my god I really
want to twerk for pewds hashtag yeah it
was like god damn I really had this
issue and I said I put that in Twitter
because I know any how to fix it and the
first response I get is don't worry no
just like you I tweeted that I broke my
camera and you'd be smartass about it so
[ __ ] you you're the same [ __ ] hey hey
that was a good response
oh it wasn't and I can show it to you
just as much as you could twig me so
[ __ ] my place where's my twerking
tired okay maybe I wanted a twerking
time just work damn it okay what am i
doing
right now what I'm good who's shooting
me Mondragon why would he target
innocent women
Oh had to be done to America apparently
only traitors twerk know what can you
broke the [ __ ] rule me with minks by
myself whenever everyone on the car
everyone in the car if I never leaves
the car you're obvious as the right to
shoot that person okay I'm gonna make
things interesting with those smoke
grenade down no don't do that why would
you do that you respect it you can't
even stay on the corner for five seconds
you're like a [ __ ] family
holy [ __ ] okay we're gonna play the odd
team who was it'll probably start
shooting with you this well obviously it
didn't but I wanted to try thank you
let's do this let's do this again
everyone in the car everyone is here
everyone is here in the car anyway let's
all do that and see how long we can stay
in the car with that [ __ ] killing
you'll have a gun I don't have a gun
okay let me go
okay okay we're not preparing you have
five seconds together I'm hotboxing guys
come on someone is not in the car it's
me I'm traffic we have the right to
shoot him within 10 flights ten you make
it nice
I'm that's what I do what does you have
in six three two one alright let's go
and kill Ken let's get him okay Jesus
Christ that's lazy we just load up we
have to stay together that's the point
yeah three of us have to stay together
the computers behind it's more like oh
yeah yeah I'm following you guys don't
worry but it makes you were behind us
first and you didn't say ok we are
obviously innocent because we were on
the card jeez did you not hear the rules
Paris by the way
no no no it's gotta be Ken I thought we
established this [ __ ] what is that
[ __ ] can describe where you are right
tell us where we are we're not gonna
kill you but say hello and you're not
gonna kill me yeah whatever
we're not gonna so hey if you were on
the car we'd all be smelly no there I
thought you guys that a gun you guys
crazy I need a gun in the first place we
don't have guns
oh yeah I have a gun ken I don't have a
gun I have no reason to lie to you I
don't have a gun I'm not gonna lie I'm
gonna have to shoot me to come out there
though I'm pretty sure the way you like
to see this other I don't I don't like
anyone getting killed hey if I made the
rules I'd say we'll just [ __ ] party
minks what are you doing wait wait I'm
so made uh put this on let's go meet up
at the car and forgive Ken okay
ken yeah you have five seconds to get in
the car yeah I got it I don't what if I
don't think I can forget him what cry
you gotta be a team player that's
everyone have worked through a [ __ ]
nade it's tense it's candy steady static
dad stop shooting me you [ __ ] [ __ ]
Hey
he's just trying to save himself oh my
god he's not please nearly dead hey
buddy well thanks the car right
[ __ ]
no it's a can bucking ken Ken I swear
the whole time buddy that was a good
shot actually if you [ __ ] listen to
my voice I said I said what did I say
what did I say you say that's the test
that's all right Kelly
with enough Tom everyone starts doubt in
each other this is why I have the rules
okay
all right guys hope you enjoyed yet
another episode the man bear leave a
like
they're dead it had my ally head
subscriber come read today I see you in
the next one
come here bro it's a better way